this video is sponsored by better help
by using the link to better help in the
description below you'll receive 10 off
your first month of affordable and
convenient online therapy
the summer was beginning and things were
going well in the small but quaint city
of dagny a bustle of summer activity
flowed the streets and an untroubled joy
filled the air
but things were about to change
quickly and dramatically
suddenly and without much warning a
weatherfront formed and moved over the
city bringing with it intense heavy
concentrated rain
water soon began to inundate the city's
drainage systems and fill the city's
impermeable streets a flash flood would
ravage the city
tens of thousands of people evacuated
thousands of others who either purposely
stayed or didn't evacuate in time became
trapped
a young woman in her mid-20s named renee
evacuated the city almost immediately
after receiving the flash flood warning
coming from a rural town about four
hours outside the city she had only
lived in dagny for about two years and
this was her first time experiencing
something like this on her own in the
city
promptly and in a panic she left and
drove to the rural town she grew up in
where her parents still lived a town
that was not expected to be as affected
by the storm and would not be subjugated
to the increased effects of urbanization
several days would go by
renee was safe but the duplex she was
renting and living in in the city would
not make it the flooding caused severe
structural damage beyond repair
soon her lease was mutually terminated
and she was suddenly faced with the need
to find a new place to live
rather scarred by the whole experience
she decided she was done living in the
city and wanted to move back into a more
rural town outside of it and so that's
what she did
several months later renee moved into a
townhouse in a town about an hour and a
half outside the city about halfway
between where she grew up and dagny
while moving in while carrying some
boxes renee happened by one of her new
neighbors a young man in his mid-20s
named steven steven noticed her moving
in and introduced himself he was both
somewhat awkward and very handsome
renee found his awkwardness kind of
endearing though surely influenced by
his handsomeness the two talked for a
few minutes and then renee continued on
about her day and finished moving in
later that day she found a note on her
door
the note read if you ever need anything
feel free to reach out and then
underneath there was a phone number and
steven's name
two days later renee decided to text
steven she didn't need anything but she
kind of wanted him they hit it off
almost right away in a way neither had
ever felt or experienced before they
seemed to almost automatically click
sharing similar senses of humor and ways
of texting and thinking and so on
two months later they were dating as the
two spent more and more time together it
almost felt as if they shared the same
path in life the same origins of the
same star stuff destined to reconnect
and rejoin like cosmic arrangements of
matter and energy faded to find its way
back to itself
soon they fell deeply in love
two years later renee and steven were
married renee's life was for the first
time in a long time going extremely well
her and stephen would form a life and
relationship together that was the kind
in quality that most people simply
cannot and will not ever find in life
on their one year wedding anniversary
renee and steven were out at dinner
celebrating
they sat reminiscing over their past and
expressing their excitement for their
future while talking about how they
first met renee said
i always used to say it and now i know
it's true
everything happens for a reason
the fact that i met you when i did after
going through everything i was i really
was honestly just at the right time in
my life to meet you and the fact that i
was pushed toward you by a literal flood
it's some kind of sign i know that that
flood was the universe's way of pushing
me onto my life's course to find you
to find this life
it's crazy but i'm so happy it happened
i love you so much steven
renee's eyes watered and her face
clenched with a soft happy sad smile
i love you too babe steven said as he
reached out with his glass
the two toasted each other both with
watering eyes
rewind about three years
another individual affected by the flood
was a 32 year old single man named
gustavo unlike renee gustavo didn't make
it out of the city before the flood he
figured the flash flood warning as it
typically was in the past was not
something to be all that concerned about
so long as he just stayed put in his
home
he had lived in dagny for a while and
floods were quite common and so he was
relatively unfazed by the situation
assuming it would come and go in a day
or so
he was of course wrong
as soon as gustavo realized how serious
the flooding was it was too late
he was trapped his home which he had
somewhat recently bought suddenly began
filling up with water as it flowed in
from the doors and windows and spewed
out through the vents items in his
living room began floating as his home
filled with water while scrambling to
try to rescue some of his important
items a large glass piece from his
coffee table when rushing toward him
smashing into his ribs and slicing the
left side of his abdomen
gustavo remained stuck in his house for
three days injured alone exposed to the
flood water and soon to become ill
as the flood began to subside and the
water in his home began to recede he was
reached by paramedics and rushed to the
hospital
gustavo arrived at the hospital in rough
shape
after running several tests it was
determined that he had a bad infection
and a fractured rib
however it was determined that he would
be okay and make a full recovery from
both
however the news was not all good
something else was very wrong in an
x-ray of his chest and ribs it was
noticed that gustavo had something on
his lungs
a tumor
gustavo was a regular smoker which was
likely the cause of what was now being
discovered as lung cancer
the tumor was still in its relatively
early stages but it appeared to likely
be aggressive and quickly developing
the doctor told gustavo that it would
likely lead to bronchial obstruction or
respiratory failure fairly soon if it
went untreated he told gustavo that if
they didn't catch it then it would have
likely been caught too late and led to
his early death
gustavo was scheduled for surgery two
weeks later to remove the cancerous
tissue before it was too late
several months would go by gustavo was
at a doctor's appointment for the first
time since the flood he was receiving a
clean bill of health the surgery was a
success ultimately saving and renewing
his life he was no longer smoking and he
was living his life normally and
vibrantly
to celebrate the news gustavo's family
threw a small party form at his favorite
restaurant
after the drinks were passed out his
family playfully pressured gustavo into
making a little speech he was a bashful
man and was a bit nervous but the
emotions and intensity of his recent
situation allowed him to tap into an
eloquent poignant part of himself that
he rarely expressed holding up a glass
of champagne gustavo said
you know when i was sitting in my attic
my entire house was filled with water i
was bleeding and i felt sick didn't know
what was going to happen i thought i was
going to die
at some point i remember thinking to
myself
why me
i prayed and i asked god
i asked him to save me to make sure i
would be okay
i begged him but as time passed and
things got worse i wondered why he
wasn't answering my prayers
why he was doing this to me
i wondered to myself what i had done
wrong
i asked him for forgiveness and for
mercy and everything
but now i see
he was there all along
he was saving me he was answering my
prayers i just didn't know it yet
god has a plan for us all
and everything happens for a reason you
just have to wait and trust in it
gustavo paused for a brief moment and
raised his now sunken glass back up
thank you all for being here with me
today to celebrate to family good health
and faith in god
cheers
the crowd covered with soft smiles
raised their glasses and let out a soft
earnest synchronized cheers
about three streets away at a different
restaurant another person who was deeply
affected by the flood was also out at
dinner it was a young woman in her
twenties named alethia she was getting
together with a few friends from high
school whom she hadn't seen recently and
only kept an occasional loose contact
with
alethia lived and worked outside the
city she was physically fine she was
healthy her house was fine her job was
fine but the flood devastated her life
her older brother aaron who lived in the
city like gustavo didn't evacuate in
time
unlike gustavo aaron tried to get out
after the flooding had started
while trying to drive out his car was
washed off the road into a flooded
culvert he suffered a head injury in the
process
he would not make it out alive
alethia was extremely close with her
brother their father passed away when
they were younger and they had been
there for each other and bonded during
and following that loss and everything
else they had been through since
now the void of her brother also weighed
heavy in her head every day
it's strange he thought how the void of
something can weigh so much more than
its presence
about halfway into the dinner with her
friends one of the girls alethia was
with named rebecca began talking about
her recent breakup with her boyfriend
while explaining how she felt about him
breaking up with her she said but you
know i just try to always remind myself
everything happens for a reason
alethea wasn't a confrontational or
argumentative person but between the
timing proximity and her mood in that
moment likely facilitated by her several
martinis that banal obscene line
everything happens for a reason
triggered something and heard that she
couldn't hold in
how
alethia said looking up from her meal
and interrupting rebecca
a pause filled a table
how what rebecca responded how does
everything happen for a reason
i don't know i mean i believe that the
universe or god or the way our energies
interact with everything or whatever you
want to call it i guess
always has a plan for us
things have a funny way of working
themselves out there's been so many
times in my life where bad things have
happened and then they've actually led
to good things for me that's just proof
that those things happen to me for a
reason
another brief pause filled the table
what if what happens kills you alethea
said abruptly
or someone you love
someone who is a good person someone who
does good in the world someone who is
young and has their whole life ahead of
them
did god do that
if he did god is a special kind of evil
if he didn't what kind of god is he
if the universe did it which of course
it did in some way it did it because of
a reason like a cause but not for a
reason
i know it's easy to think that things
happen for a reason when they work out
for you we all love the comfort that
someone or something is looking out for
us and is making sure we are okay
but for every event that people claim
happen for a reason a good reason there
are innumerable other people affected by
the exact same event who aren't okay and
wouldn't say it happened for a good
reason because there's no one left to
say anything at all
things just happen and if you're lucky
enough to still be alive after they do i
guess you can look for a reason or try
and make one up
but that's as good as it gets
another pause filled a table this one
was much longer
then rebecca said
well if you are alive
is that not enough
[Music]
thank you so much for watching this
video was sponsored by better help
it is truly an accomplishment in it of
itself to stay sane in this world pain
and suffering are always inevitable for
a large intelligence and a deep heart
wrote novelist theodore dostoevsky those
among us who think a lot and intensely
are blessed with a unique and deep
perspective but are also often cursed
with an anxiety overwhelm or despair
that is especially heavy
there is a point at which these feelings
can and do exceed the weight limit we
ought to reasonably carry on our own
betterhelp is a platform that offers
licensed therapists who are trained to
listen and help you carry that weight by
either helping you to reduce it or
develop the strength to better carry it
seeing a licensed therapist provides
something that nothing else quite does
dedicated in open support on the aspects
of your life that most conversations
will never quite touch
one of the things that makes betterhelp
so great is that they take out the
additional stress and anxiety of
locating changing and dealing with the
therapist's office when you're already
feeling overwhelmed this makes a big
difference
with better help you talk to your
therapist privately online through video
or phone calls as well as exchange
unlimited messages whenever you want
wherever you want meaning if you don't
want to see anyone visually you don't
have to and if the therapist you're
matched with is not quite the right fit
you can easily request a new one at no
additional charge anytime betterhelp has
over 20 000 therapists in their network
covering a wide range of expertise which
also provides you access to a greater
pool of therapists you wouldn't have
otherwise all you have to do is fill out
a questionnaire and then you'll be
matched with an appropriate therapist in
under 48 hours whether you're
experiencing overwhelming ruminations
stress sadness or simply just want some
help keeping your head on straight
better help that's better help makes it
easier to take charge of your mental
health by visiting betterhelp.com
pursuit of wonder or using the link in
the description below you can sign up
and receive a special 10 off your first
month
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
you